Speaker 1: The deranged hellscape that is
the modern American right wing just continues
to get worse, I want to look at a couple of
data points for you guys last night, quite
literally, as Vladimir Putin and Russia started
bombing in Ukraine, sending missiles to Kiev
and Kharkiv and all over the country, quite
literally.
Donald Trump again praised Vladimir Putin,
this time at a very strange speech he gave
at his own Mar a Lago resort.
Now, yesterday I brought you the clip of Donald
Trump saying on this podcast hosted by Buck
Sexton and another guy, Trump saying that
Putin was savvy and smart and genius for what
he did to Ukraine.
And some people, said David.
That was taken out of context.
Well, Trump doubled down on it again.
Here is Donald Trump at a Mar a Lago event
last night, saying Putin is smart.
He's taken a country over for two dollars
worth of sanctions.
I'd say that's pretty smart.
Take a look at this, Trump said.
Speaker 2: Putin smart.
I mean, he's taking over a country for two
dollars worth of sanctions.
I'd say that's pretty smart.
Speaker 1: Trump is saying, Yeah, it is smart.
It is smart.
Trump's actually responding to the people
who said, wow to buck Sexton.
Trump said, how smart Putin is.
That's crazy, and Trump is going.
It is smart.
What Putin is doing is smart.
Now, I understand in this clip, he's not saying
I support it, but he's clearly enamored with
the authoritarian nature of Putin, as we've
known for years.
Speaker 2: He's taking over the country, though
really a vast, vast location, a great piece
of
Speaker 1: land with a lot of people.
And it's just great real estate that Putin's
gotten for two bucks of sanctions, just
Speaker 2: walking right in.
This would have never happened.
Never in a million years would have never
happened.
I know very well.
I know probably almost as well as I know anybody
who has thriving.
Speaker 1: Well, if Trump really has the relationship
with Putin that that he claims to have.
And if this really would never have happened
if Trump was currently in power, why doesn't
Trump just call Putin and say, Hey, it's time
to lay off Ukraine?
I mean, Trump wants us to believe that Putin
respects Trump.
Trump wants us to believe that Putin listens
to Trump and that Trump has power of over
Putin.
Well, if you don't like what he's doing, just
call him and say, Hey, it's time to lay off.
And of course, the answer is either because
Trump doesn't have that relationship with
Putin or because he likes what Vladimir Putin
is doing now.
He's certainly impressed with it.
I don't think Trump cares at all about Ukraine.
I think Trump is probably indifferent about
Putin invading Ukraine.
Trump doesn't care about Ukrainians or Ukraine,
but he can't just say, I love the invasion.
Instead, he has to just talk about how smart
Vladimir Vladimir Putin is.
Imagine for a second, by the way, if Trump
was president when this was going on, it would
be like another rehash of when Trump met with
Putin in Helsinki and asked him about the
hacking where he's like, Oh, Putin denied
it very strongly.
I just spoke to Putin, and he says the invasion
is fine.
I asked him, Did you do anything wrong?
And he said, Sir, no, everything we're doing
in Ukraine is OK.
And he said it very strongly.
It was a very Putin was very strong on it.
So I believe him, the invasion is fine.
That's what would be going on.
And if you think this is bonkers, just wait
until we look at these next series
of clips.